why screenwriting that's a great
question to start with uh I I think it's
just basically
um two things and
one is
um when when I was young
um the thing that
came before I wanted to tell stories
which I think is very integral to
to wanting to write screenplays
uh is a is a love for movies and a love
for Cinema and so I think I just became
like a movie addict first
um without any sort of concern
whatsoever for
the idea of writing a screenplay
um just just kind of getting a rush from
from movies and watching movies and
talking about movies and and uh
wanting to introduce my my friends to
movies so
for me I think that was the the the
first the the amuse Bouche on the pallet
before I launched into into storytelling
um storytelling was something else
um storytelling was the the idea that
there was
um a message that I wanted to convey
um a statement that I wanted to say and
you usually like and and that didn't
really sort of progress until I for me
um I was in my early 20s
I
I had these ideas and I would see these
these great films from from people that
were expressing
um at the time for me
um these kind of subjects that dealt
with things that that hit me in the
heart and in um at my core
um for who I was a young adult as a
young black male adult
and
um one example of course would be um
well two examples would be John
Singleton and Spike Lee
um and um
and I and I thought hey you know I want
to tell stories that have like messages
that are akin to that that have that
kind of you know that that that that
relate to you know to to to people like
me
so
um that was the impetus
and then I went on a journey of trying
to discover how to do that
um
and um
and that
um that entailed
um
um mining what I love about
um the written word
um and um and and and and and and and
that also involves you know A love of
literature
um
uh love of Storytelling of all types I
think that that screenplays are usually
just elaborate short stories
um just unspooled and and in a in a slow
fashion
um across um 12 beats which would make
it three acts but
um but yeah I I hope that wasn't too
long no it was perfect you said
something about uh mining the written
word that's interesting yeah well it it
and what I mean by that is is that
um
when it comes to writing screenplays
specifically
um you're telling us a story in pictures
and to tell a story in pictures you have
to use these um these blunt little tools
that are called words
and you have to find new and different
ways to use those words juxtapose those
words abuse those words even
um to to make a picture out of a scene
uh if you if you have a scene in which
there isn't any sort of banter if the
you don't have two characters exchanging
dialogue you have to create
what amounts to an interpretation or a
blueprint that
um that the director is going to work
from and the and and and and on all the
other attendant people involved
so
that is mining the written word you you
have to find the right words to do so
you know so I mean so even as I speak
right now you'll find
you know this is this affects I think
the DNA of of writers and screenwriters
because
um I think writers intrinsically are
always seeking you know even as I speak
the right word to use because when it
comes to to writing you're sitting there
you're being still you're being patient
if you are if you were uh
um born sometime before
um 1980 you were in front of a blank
page if you were born somewhere after
1990 you know you were you're in um
you're in front of a blank screen and
you're waiting
you're waiting to get just the right
word to string next to another word to
get right
to be correct
um approximation of what you want
the um the the director or producer or
even the reader to take away from the
experience of that scene
how long have you been doing this I've
been
I've been writing scripts
um in
you know
a scattered fashion for
um
I'll be told
um like about like 23 years
um
and yeah that's long and short
23 years and so
was there a point when you almost walked
away from screenwriting absolutely
or should I ask which time or what
happened
like like
um
I'd say a few times
um early in the game
um especially when it seemed really hard
but the thing that kept bringing me back
was was pretty easy is it wouldn't let
me go you know I I think
that's a complex thing to answer because
I think if um you intrinsically
feel you know called to write
um you know people say that and it
sounds really pretentious it's like it's
like you were called to be a part of the
monastery like you're a Jesuit somewhere
and since this is not I I know it sounds
pretentious but it it does actually
exist in and if you um if you survey a
number of writers they will they will
sometimes use that phrase
because they they find that they can't
they can't pull themselves or wrestle
some wrestle themselves away from the
computer
that they have to come back and they
have to work at something because it's
nagging at them and it won't it won't
stop nagging at them until until it's
finished
and so for me it was like that and it
only was it was only when after a period
of time in which it started to become a
little facile it started to become a
little easy that I you know I was like
okay well I'm I'm just going to keep
going you know so
um there are other things too
um there's
um there's little lessons that you learn
along the way
um there's there's examples
um from from other writers that you pick
up that um give you um a really strong
skill set to um to to use and to borrow
from that
make it real real simple in my mind
um
you know I could I can expound on that
for like like oh maybe two hours
and that I'm actually not kidding so uh
if we wanted to get into that but but
yeah there's stuff like that
so you found it got easier for you and
you were okay with the fact that
there was something
sort of pulling you to do this that it
was it was it almost felt like it was
beyond your control
yeah
um absolutely
um it's yeah that's basically what it is
um if if I wanted to
um
to get a little bit more flowery about
it you know you know some people you
know some people believe in a higher
power some people believe in a muse
you know so
um there there I think that um with
writing you know there's always
something that um
that is pulling you
towards writing it
and the story
and what kind of stories were you pulled
toward I mean you said there were
certain filmmakers John Singleton Spike
Lee that you wanted to emulate that you
wanted to make movies similar to theirs
yeah yeah in the beginning
um
in the beginning I was very um
interested in writing stories
um that were were kind of
um
carbon copies of uh of the kind of
stories that they were telling uh uh
that that soon started to evolve
um I started become interested in
telling a little bit more
um
action-oriented
almost
elongated well not really elongated but
like a sort of cinematic comic book
um ask type stories because I love comic
books and I grew up on comic books and
and that started to become incorporated
into the kind of
um writing I was doing and all the while
as I was developing my craft I was you
know as usual seeing more movies more
kinds of movies different kinds of
movies I'm a big proponent of
um of writing styles that aren't
um exclusive to what happens in
Hollywood or in America I think that
what happens in Europe and and Britain I
think the Hong Kong
um filmmakers and writers are
excellent
um I think you know for example of
course you know John Wu wonkar y
um the European filmmakers
um Michael Hanukkah Christoph kislowski
um Mike Lee
these are all
um the they all provide a different
um a different set of tools that you can
also bring and use and so along the way
I found myself almost kind of coming
full circle back to what I wanted to
tell in the first place or the kind of
stories I wanted to tell in the first
place but with a more assured voice with
my voice
as opposed to being
more of a
carbon copy or a copy you know
Michael Clayton
um interesting love that movie
um
um why I love that movie is a couple
reasons
um I think that that one of the finest
filmmakers and writers and the business
is Tony Gilroy
is his
his work is indelible
um the the his screenplays are
extraordinary if you want to talk about
terse terse action suspense drama
um and and and and any kind of suspense
that feels rooted in reality as opposed
to being too cartoonish that is um Tony
Gilroy and
um if you know for anyone he doesn't you
know know his um
his um attach his name to to his films
we're talking
um the devil's advocate he wrote he
wrote the the the the the the first
three Bourne movies
um and of course
um the the gorgeous
um and um and Beautiful film uh Michael
Clayton which is basically about a
character
um about a man who is um as I was saying
a little earlier is um is stuck in a
sort of nomad slant
um because he has um
he has this this he's burdened by by
being able to do certain things that
don't don't that render him anti-social
um in the world
um yet he's still a very um useful
figure he he's a commodity and
um he's uh he's he's a commodity that um
is to the detriment of his um of his own
um his own well-being in in many ways
so
um
love that film
um what's really great about that film
now
is what it does and what what it Blends
is that it it takes all the excitement
um that you get all the boys stuff that
you like you know if you're a boy
um with um with um you know
um bad guys and and and and and and good
guys and and and good triumphing over
evil and and or and and the gray areas
that exist in between and it marries it
with um with with drama that is really
really
um I think socially
um relevant and gives a message and
hearkens back to a lot of those um
70s films and those are the films I grew
up on and where the where the films that
I became a fan of
um when I was a kid
um those were films like Sydney lamet's
films
um like um Dog Day Afternoon or
or Serpico or um you know
any any really any of those network
network
phenomenal but yeah
right and and where you were talking
about the the gray area in between and
and sometimes where the gangster in the
film is not actually the worst character
in the end we find out that it was the
the one that had the appearance of
sort of the the straight and narrow but
actually where where sort of their
morals got you know it's interesting I
feel like
um I'm not even sure where I'm going
with that I know we were watching
something moral ambiguity okay okay
moral and that's the word okay thank you
and and and and
discovering that in a character because
you it's not always close it's not
always obvious to the the audience and
when we find that the one that we
suspected was the bad one actually had
more of
um a code of honor or ethics than one
that looked squeaky clean and we thought
we could trust so
um it's it's those gray areas and yeah
absolutely that's that's what I that's
what I enjoy
um about that kind of work
um I think that that you know
I personally and I don't think everyone
feels the same way but I feel that work
like that that enlightens you about
um areas of the human condition is
edifying because you have you you grow
an insight and then you have the
potential to take that insight
whether it is creatively or otherwise
you take it and you can potentially
evolve yourself you know so that's
Christian what's more fun for you
writing your screenplays or reading them
[Laughter]
I don't sometimes I don't even know if I
like writing my screenplays I I
I'm usually starting a screenplay sucks
uh Brad part usually sucks
when you get in the zone oh yeah that's
it
Zone of writing a script
um that's when it gets really you you
get jonesed that means that you actually
enjoy uh waking up at um seven to eight
a.m even sometimes earlier
um like around six and you put on the
coffee and sit down in front of the
computer and and keep keep moving it
Forward because you're you're confident
as to where all the pieces fit and where
where you're going and even if you're
not confident you know that you're it's
like you're getting in the car again
after a pit stop
um running the Le Mans and you're and
you you know you're going to win the
race if you if you as long as you you
know keep the lug bolts on the on the
tires
so um so
that's that's that's when it's fun but
sometimes it takes a while to get to
that place I do realize that
um for some people it never is fun
um in the process it's it's it you can
be slogging it out quite a bit and I do
recall when it was for me it was never
fun writing it
um until I got to the to the second
draft
you know until I got to rewriting then
I'd go oh wait no this is no this is not
that bad
[Laughter]
I feel like I was like digging through
you know a pile of trash that I'm
salvaging some articles that didn't need
to be thrown away but but
but but yeah
that's that's when for me
um now that it gets fun
um
I
don't take any particular pride out of
reading anything
I've written
I don't
it's I don't know I guess it it's sort
of like like watching yourself on screen
you know
um which is a meta thing to say as this
is occurring
um I I don't I I I don't think I I it
doesn't occur to me to want to read
anything I've written you know
um other than to check it for mistakes
or errors and to you know to make sure
that it aligns properly in accordance to
to structure and um and you know that
sort of thing
so writing the first draft at times can
be sounds like energizing but at other
times not
well I mean it's energizing when you're
like I said when you're in the zone so
the meaning like
so
you start writing
and
for me
and I'm I'm gonna I'm a preface this by
saying because you referenced this
before we we start talking about the
debate of of outlining and when I was uh
when I was a kid or when I was younger I
should say
um I did quite a bit of outlining and I
I learned a specific method
on how to outline from some very
reputable folks
and I've abandoned them entirely I don't
recommend that to anyone if
um if somebody's new writing
um outlining is absolutely essential in
my mind I know people have differing
opinions about that but it's absolutely
essential but I do think that once you
have a grasp of what you're doing that
you can feel absolutely free to get get
rid of it when you're ready when you
find your voice
um there there's you know there's a
thing it's like it's like um you know
it's like the
Picasso analogy you know it's like it's
like once you know the rules you can
throw them away you know Picasso was a
fine uh naturalistic painter
at age 10.
okay
age ten all right by the time he's in
his early 20s he can start to experiment
yeah
saying
um applies to um
to screenwriting I believe so
for me
um I start a script and I have like a
satellite number of notes those notes
are usually jotted down in on something
these days they're in my phone I um I I
I use the note field and I throw little
ideas in there sometimes bits of
dialogue and things like that when they
accumulate to a point and there's a
number of these going on at once I mean
a number of story ideas when they
accumulate to a point I open up a
a a file on my um my computer and I
start
um I start stringing those notes
together
once though I start stringing those
notes together I'll transfer those to a
final draft file and I'll start spacing
them out
like I'm piecing together a puzzle like
um like um you know you take a puzzle
and you start with the edges first
you know I will go oh this might go like
around here in the story and this might
go around here in the story and this
might go around here and then I
repeatedly return to that final draft
file
and stare at it and go hmm let's put
something in here and let's put
something in there and let's put
something in here
and continually build it based on that
rubric
and then when it starts to become
something fulsome
and it
I start to get energized by it
I might spend more time on it so like
two hours three hours once I'm I'm
spending like six hours a day on it
it's happening
you know I'm I'm I'm at that point I'm
in the zone
and I'm just I'm I'm like
forgetting sometimes to get lunch
because I'm so
um
and I'm so wrapped up in the story
there you go
I believe you've referenced Dorothy
Parker many times where you say the
famous remark of hers I hate to write I
love having written you know we were
talking a little bit about her off
screen how do you relate to that quote
um well absolutely relate to that quote
um
writing is is hard
um it's um it's it's tough
um for a couple of reasons there's two
sides of that coin that the actual
activity itself
um is um is taxing and it requires a lot
of patience
and and also it is one of those um
chosen vocations where one is likely to
suffer a great deal of critique scrutiny
and attack
so
um all of that together makes it you
know makes it tough so you have to you
have to sort of build a sort of thick
skin now the with that comes the the
great myths of um of the writers and and
you know and all the all the the the
writers that um I can think of
um and then this is cross all genres of
writing
uh um most of them have this Aura of
strength and promotion promotion of that
strength as a writer and in their
writing
um and you know those and the finest
examples of it is Dorothy Parker is a
probably one of the one of the you know
the um the the Pinnacles of that of of
that idea of strength
um as well as someone you know of course
like Ernest Hemingway
um Hunter S Thompson James Baldwin
um all of these characters convey
strength and um
and that is a um is a quality
that comes from having to deal with the
rigors
of being a writer of putting in those
hours of spending that time of building
your voice as a writer and to have
conviction
as a writer
and and it also speaks to something a
little bit that we talked about just a
few minutes ago which was that the
character that you were referring to in
Michael Clayton and that is they don't
really fit in this box they don't fit in
that box they kind of
there's not really a place for them but
they can't just fade away this is true
this is absolutely true I think that
that's a really that's an interesting
analogy and an interesting point that
you're bringing up
um
I think that
that once you go down the road
um as
is it um
I always get I'm thorough and Emerson
I'm confused but I believe it was
throw
um the road not taken so to speak
um once you go down the road not taken
you know a friend of mine used to say
you know it's you know it gets a little
sketchy down there because the road not
taken is often patrolled by the cops
so so
uh once you go down that road don't
expect
um to not face adversity
you know
um
and don't expect it to not change you
don't expect to not
um
to not make you something that you don't
expect that you're going to be
you will you will more than likely
become smarter wiser you will you will
have survival skills that
um you probably didn't expect that you
would gain
but
it will turn you into something else
that's really interesting
For Better or Worse yes you're right I
like what you said how going down this
road that that's you know there's
there's not um it's kind of a dark murky
Road where you're not really sure what's
in the shadows but it also is maybe sort
of a metaphor for what a lot of writers
have been maybe more alone or I know
Outcast is is not the right word but um
they're used to having to be their own
strength well I mean
to to a degree I mean like
I I know a lot of writers and I spent a
lot of time around writers this is a
whole other subject matter we can get
into this
in a bit
but
um
but um
being alone as a writer is not so bad
um because writers aren't really alone
it's a
it's um
it's a kind of Illusion because writers
are
besieged with the often with especially
if they're writing stories they're
besieged with with characters that live
with them
so and it's it's it's this it's this
misnomer to say a writer is alone in
fact it's like writers
writers in a sense if you want to if you
want to call them you know anti-social
they aren't anti-social
um by you know I think by
um by Nature they're anti-social by
choice
because they just want to get back to
the people they know
[Laughter]
or the people that that they're
currently entertained with
and
um and I think that um
I think that that's um really what it is
um
I I think also conversely many writers
are extraordinarily gregarious
um
um my my personal Mo I think is that I
have two sides
um
and those two sides are I can be
incredibly quiet totally bashful really
shy
um a real introvert and then I swing way
to the other side and I can be
incredibly
um gregarious and an extrovert and and
highly social and you know and loud and
boisterous and all those things I don't
know what that means
um and um but I do know that that it
that is not
um that is not something that is unusual
that that many many writers are fill
that mold
what are your core beliefs about
pursuing a writing career that's like
huge
um that is and what I mean by huge is
like there's so many things there
um the the the the the main thing is
um for me is you just have to be
um committed and you have to have
passion
um as a as a writer
um regardless of what genre of writer
writing you're working on
um I think that first and foremost that
you have to consider yourself a writer
not a screenwriter but rather a writer
that's just me some people might say I'm
otherwise but you really have to
consider yourself a writer because if
you don't understand how
how
how to take writing out of the re the
arena of solely just
um crafting spec scripts
Pilots for TV and and feature
screenplays you're never going to really
develop
um some Innovative skills at actually
doing those things that catch people's
you know attention
so I think that's very important so that
all falls under the ballpark of
commitment and passion
um so that means that you basically you
you you need your your friend is a is
like um is a cup of coffee
and your your your seat in front of that
you know that computer screen those are
your friends
and you better get comfortable with them
you know
um
because you're gonna need them
you know you have to you have to spend
the time
um to to learn to do
um what you want to do and also
this is the other thing you know
um it's an excavation
um and it's not an excavation of the of
the work that's in front of you per se
although it can be it's an excavation of
yourself because you start to realize
who you are as a writer you start to
realize that like let's say like you
know we're using a a baseball
um analogy you throw a mean curveball
you know you start to and you go oh wait
wait I throw a mean curveball you know
it's like um well let me let me work on
that a little bit you know sort of thing
so
um that that's what you start to learn
about yourself but first you you might
you might you know just think you're
just a good shortstop
you know when you begin you know before
you discover
your own peculiar talents
when was that clear to you
that's an interesting uh question
and um
that's going to be fun to talk about
um
when that was clear to me was
um I I
um I when I started writing in general
I wrote a lot of poetry and I enjoyed
writing poetry and
the craft of writing poetry
and so I thought that maybe it would be
easy to use what I know from from poetry
writing
to to develop
writing screenplays I I I wrote my first
screenplay and I had the great Fortune
to to meet and for a short period of
time
received some mentorship from from a guy
who who took a little bit of interest in
me a a director from Old School from Old
School Hollywood
named Ted post
and he was very very gracious and
generous to um to offer to read my first
screenplay and
he read in he got back in touch with me
and he said to me goes christian you
know I gotta tell you you know it's like
I think you got some Talent
I think you know how to write some
dialogue but you have no idea how to
tell a story
it's like and I'm like oh wow okay
gee tell me what's really easy exactly
you know and but thanks you know and
he's like I want you to go out and I
want you to buy this book
and um
I I bought this book called The Art of
dramatic writing
the most important book I one of the
most important books I should say and
I've read in terms of my writing
definitely the
um the book that helped set me off on on
the journey
but LA Los agreon I hope I'm pronouncing
that correctly and
um and um
the book is um is not so much about
um
writing for the movies as it is the the
classical elements of telling story as
it relates to
um to the plays of Ibsen Shakespeare
um even a few more modern plays of of
the of the early
um the early 20th century such as on
O'Neill's plays and whatnot
and that really started to break down
for me what I understood to be structure
but even then
I was still a bit flummoxed on how to
find a a way
to have a confidence
when I would attack a screenplay because
I was like okay there's this over here
and
um I have I think I have a good idea of
of of voice and characters and and
writing you know interesting dialogue
but I not so sure how to marry the two
so I had written in one script
and um
and some people were responding to it
um
pretty well and almost like a lukewarm
fashion but they were like oh it's you
know it's it's got a middle a beginning
a middle and an ending
and
I um I stumbled across
um
um a copy of Shane Black's the long kiss
goodnight
and I noticed specifically how Shane
wrote his screenplays
um these um terse little bursts
of of word formations
to to convey the atmosphere
of
um of the of the action lines and the
descriptions of each scene
um just it was just so exciting to read
that and to and how kinetic it was and
how how he sort of
just kind of like broke rules certain
rules not like not broke rules just to
break rules but just
broke certain rules so that he could he
could meet certain um
um objectives
um in a very targeted fashion
and I thought to myself well like I I
can do that that's not I can I I see
what he's doing I see the architecture
underneath it and I can I can definitely
do that and furthermore I found it very
relayed a great deal to to what it was
like to writing poetry because poetry is
often very
um
um elastic with with with language and
with words
and and and and and Shane's work was
very elastic
so
um with with words and sentences and the
grammar with kid paid no attention to
grammar really
um it was just all about getting you to
understand the scene
and so um I I took that on and I rewrote
that that screenplay that I had and then
boom lots of people were all love that
script
um and in fact
um it it it it it it secured me a
finalist position with um Tribeca access
um soon after that and that's when I
knew I was on to something that's when I
realized like hey I can do this now I I
know what to do I have I have all my I
have all all the paints in my um in in
my box of paints so yeah
should someone be fearful with building
their entertainment career or at least
cautious
um
yeah I guess so but you know mostly be
Fearless because what I mean by that is
um is that um
there
are so many
forces
that want to strip you of your voice as
a writer
um and to make you compromise that voice
to um
to make undermine that voice and confuse
you into thinking that you should
undermine your voice
and that's ridiculous that's absolutely
ridiculous
um
the the the the greatest the greatest
writers
um in screenwriting
um we we
know who they are
simply because
not only when we read the scripts you
know their voice is um is apparent and
and and and Rises to the surface but
when we we see the the finished products
it's apparent I mean it's like how would
you how do you how do you separate you
know I mean you know the sound of
Tarantino
you know
you know I mean it's like you know you
know the sound of Diablo Cody
you know you you know the sound of of
Spike Lee I mean these people have
sounds
you know
that's your voice and if you're not
working
um you know you if you're not you know
sharpening your quiver to towards that
to towards that direction
then you're not going to ever sort of
stand out from the crowd because that's
what ultimately is the goal that's what
makes you you know if we're going back
to our Michael Clayton analogy that
makes you the the the commodity that
cannot be
um
um avoided that that people have to come
to in the end it's going well we need
him to do this you know we need we need
to call we need to call up
um um um um
um oh I'm forgetting her name is it
Phoebe Waller
um Bridge we need to call her to punch
up a script you know because we need
that voice
we need that voice and and and and and
and all you need to do is say her name
and you know what her voice means
to that to that project
it is it is absolutely absolutely
Paramount
that every writer get to that space
because then you know people you know
agents producers Executives they're
they're they're they get bombarded with
crap
you know they get
bombarded with a lot of the same of this
are a lot of you know like this or you
know or or people people that sound like
Sam back
people that's like this you know people
like you know that's you know that that
want to be David peoples people that you
know
and
um
they don't really want that
they want you
they want to know who you are
you know they want something that's so
unique
and
um that that they can go oh well you
know nobody else has that so this is
this is the One-Stop shop where you can
go to it's a you only can go to that
store to get that
that's it you said I think writing
screenplays specifically is a love for
the art storytelling
yeah yeah and that uh sort of dovetails
to what I was discussing before
um a little bit with um mining
um the written word but um
um yeah it's when I'm but also just to
elaborate on that it's it's really the
classic
um
it's the classic example of
um having that um that command of
telling a story around a campfire
and
um to take people through a journey that
um that keeps them
um entertained but also leaves them with
um
with um with something
um something that sort of delights them
in a special way
um that is The Art of Storytelling that
is the um
um the thing that has occurred time and
memoriam since you know the cavemen were
drawing on drawing on the the sides of
uh of the caves so it's the it's that's
that's what I'm speaking of speaking to
and that's what you do
um with um with the screenplays the
first is this is the first
um
brick in in building that wall
um the wall where it will be projected
eventually it's
um you know the theater is the big
um it's the big cave that we all we all
um huddle inside
I like that
so it's not just the love of the final
product which is seeing these characters
come to life and getting an audience
reaction to will they laugh at this part
will they gasp at this part but also
just the the real love for crafting it
and and
ruminating over this word or should this
character enter here or there well I
think that
um all filmmakers and what I mean by all
filmmakers is that all
um all Crafts People in the art of
filmmaking from the writer to um to the
production designer to the actor to the
director
um to hopefully the producers uh
um have a a passion for telling stories
and that's where that's where everyone
collaborates that's where everyone comes
together
because they go how can we tell this
story in the best possible way because
everyone's excited about that Prospect
and that notion it's actually
um a larger than it's larger than anyone
one person's
um aspect on on the production is no one
is the sole Avatar of that of that
objective
you know it's like oh how can we tell
this this great story we're all excited
about you know
how can we succeed at that
do you think when a writer reaches a
certain level they no longer need to
work on Craft no
just no that you got to remain teachable
um as a writer
um
it's uh
I think it's extraordinarily important
um
you know you always have to be willing
to learn and I think
that
um
writers tend to give off this air that
they're like poor man intellectuals
um I don't I I don't think they really
are
uh I I think that they
um I think that they
they have to continually
be in a process in which they are
allowing themselves to be vulnerable and
open to to new things I think they do a
good act and
um at seeming to be having
um
a wide array of knowledge there's
there's the writers actually do talk
about this um there's a lecture that
incidentally Tony Gilroy
um gives where he basically talks about
um how um how writers have this amazing
capacity to know a little bit about so
many various subject matters but not
never an extensive amount about one
thing you know we are I think in a sense
you know dilettante by by Nature
you know in other words yes we we have
to be open you know we can't
you know there's there's no
so you gotta you always got to be
practicing you always have to be
honing your work
um you're always willing to learn from
somebody else
um
um there's I learned so much from from
other writers I love to listen to to
other writers talk about how they do
things and um and and certain techniques
and ideas they apply I think any true
writer is um is a curiosity Junkie
um that there it's just it's just that
they're
they're just need to keep getting more
information you know about whatever you
know whatever it is how's this work or
how does that you know that's
interesting you know
um
you know even if it just flies in one
ear and then out the other later you
know we are curiosity junkies so
what is a poor man or poor woman's
intellectual what is that
I like that
what I mean by that is it is like is is
that I think that writers do a good job
of sounding good
um of
um
sounding like they know what they're
talking about
um I think
um
um there is a there's a kind of um
sometimes
the kind of intellectual arrogance some
writers can have
um but I don't think by Nature
being a writer
um
is a
is a prerequisite or or any any kind of
standard for your intellectual capacity
whatsoever
um I I I I you know just because you you
have a large vocabulary doesn't make you
a professor
um and and
often I do believe others get that
confused including the writers
themselves
so we believe our own height oh yeah
Jack of all trades now there you go
there you go you just explained it in
such and and in terms that are far more
simpler than I just did hence hence
hence you know um you know explaining
what I was there you have it well I
think I'm further down on the scale I
haven't I haven't mastered total total
intellectual but what I'm curious is of
um how can we tell if we're not
teachable
you talked about become being teachable
and that's something that we never stop
you know getting to that point where
you've never mastered the craft but how
do we know how can we check ourselves
that's easy
you just gotta listen
that's it you know if you aren't if you
aren't spending enough time listening
it's pretty easy
you know
that's that that's how I think that
basically you have to check yourself if
you're if you're teachable you got to
listen to people
um you you you have to um you have to
listen to what others are doing
um
and if it jibes with you
that's cool if it doesn't that's fine
you can you can go and do your own thing
but it doesn't mean that you um you need
to block it out or you have to discount
it because obviously it works for them
and you don't have to hold any judgment
over it either
you think there are times when we become
unteachable and then we kind of vastly
back to being teachable and and it's
like this battle
I think that um I think that that's a
larger life question
and that that that
um
that comes with a bit of wisdom as a
writer
um if you're if you're a young writer
you may and you you achieve a modicum of
success you may start to believe that
you are
um you're beyond any kind of um
um
growth
that you can't develop any further and
at your craft
and then you you might turn around and
go no I was absolutely wrong you know
it's like you know I I do have more to
learn
so I don't think that um
I I don't think that that's just a
straight
writer inquiry I think there's a larger
It's a larger question it goes towards
life
and one last life question and that is
do you think having early success is a
curse
these are deep philosophical areas
you're getting into
um that's my own believing my own hype
but I am curious I don't know
um because I wouldn't I wouldn't know
the experience of
I mean either
um but I think that maybe I've heard
some writers suggest that they feel that
they were
um stifled because they received early
success
um I have experience I'm with writers
and I've known writers and and in
Intimate ways that um I know that
they've had issues with success
um because it's um it's a very um it's
it's a seismic thing to occur
and
often you might get confused and
attribute it
to to something that is beyond
um
Beyond even your um even the product
that you that you put out there
um and if you do that then you you can
you can lose your way you know at you
know at the thing that you love to do
the most or if that is writing
um then you could maybe
um you know lose them lose a little time
you know
um
um writing the kind of things that you
want to write and and developing the
kind of projects you want to work on
but um yeah yeah
I've heard of such a thing
yeah it reminds me of one of one of the
scenes I love in the movie um end of the
tour I believe about David Foster
Wallace and the Rolling Stone journalist
that comes to his house in Illinois
interviews him for a week no I've never
seen that oh it's so good and I know it
got a lot of criticism I loved it I know
there were people that had their
criticisms of it but that the David
Foster Wallace character says I cherish
my regular guyness
that's something I really cherish and I
I'm just assuming that he meant sort of
like not believing the hype you know he
was this Young Writers 24 I believe when
infinite just came out and and just
making sure that he cherished that
regular part of himself again I'm I'm
projecting onto that but I'm I'm I just
love that scene because you know here's
this young journalist played by Jesse
Eisenberg that's coming to interview him
and pick them apart and find out what
makes them sick and just you know the
two bond is friends and it's anyway
for reminding me of that when you talked
about that so
I have to see that now yeah I loved it I
mean there's a lot of sad parts to it um
but um it's based on a real interview
that a journalists did with him keeping
with the subject the writer who lands
success with the first screenplay
is a fantasy mm-hmm why do we still
think this is different for us
individually
what do you mean well so many people
think it's going to be different for me
oh yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna this is
different I know other people took them
15 years to get this one film made but
they haven't seen my work yet yeah it's
I don't know it's it's really weird
um it's um
it's it's it's a funny thing
um when people approach it that way
uh
to this day I find it
I find it not only cautionary but uh I
kind of find it tragic that a lot of
people
um come to Hollywood or just in general
um
come here with this hope this um this um
this dream that they can they can do
this one thing
um and I think that the trend has been
for the last 30 years about that you can
write this knockout one time screenplay
get it to the right person and somehow
um magically you will become a star
screenwriter
um I think that um a part of that has to
do with the um
the the celebrity that has been attached
to the to the screenwriting profession
recently well when I said recently I
mean their last 30 years
um
it it wasn't like that always
um it was a it was a very behind the
scenes
profession and and now it has a a a
it has this uh this this heightened
patina of notoriety that people
um aspire to
um it's like you know people wanted to
come to to to to
go go to go to Hollywood in the 60s so
they could become you know lead
guitarists for some band you know it's
the same it's the same
elusive objective
you know this is so gruesome but you
just triggered this memory of when I
first came to La one of the first things
I saw was a girl that had jumped from
her balcony
and we may cut this but her body was
covered and the neighbors were all
watching this is in Hollywood and it was
like a four-story balcony and I never
forgot that image because I always
wondered who was she why did she jump
what I mean she was living in this nice
apartment much nicer than the place I
lived in but what would prompt her and
and I guess just a reminder of that and
being so young coming here and seeing
like this
you can fall I guess is the analogy yeah
I know I'm going on a gruesome take here
but it never left me you know
[Music]
no no I I yeah who what what was her
background I mean like it's like um
my my circumstances
um here are um are
well they're they're actually quite
convenient
um I'm from I'm from Los Angeles
um I had no ever desire to um to get
into writing or writing screenplays it
just was something that I was compelled
to do
um I think and and furthermore I wasn't
compelled necessarily just to write
screenplays I started out writing poetry
and I just want it right
you know I think that that's pretty much
the healthiest mode in which anyone
starts writing anything
you know they're writers
um they um they want to write and then
it then when they they identify Oh I
wanna I wanna I wanna do a screenplay oh
I want to really screenplay then it's
like oh great go ahead write a
screenplay you know
um I do I don't think your first
screenplay will is likely to probably
get you anywhere but
um if you keep writing screenplays you
will learn
and and once you start to learn
um you will you will hit a screenplay
that'll you know we'll turn some heads
you know it's that's that isn't uncommon
that isn't a fantasy
because it happens
it happens pretty much every day
that is not a fantasy what is a fantasy
is if you come out here with one
screenplay and you're gonna knock it out
the part and you think that that's all
you need to do because that ain't
happening
do you ever envision your script sitting
in a pile on someone's desk or maybe in
their study on a weekend and think
what's going to make mine
stand out here
what chance do I have yeah absolutely
the way I look at that you know and this
is that the risk of sounding redundant
is you know I've talked about the whole
aspect of the voice but you know the the
voice is one thing but you know I in in
my case I'm confident in my voice now
you go on you move on to that other word
which is confidence
so with that with with with confidence
um you what you want to do when you have
like a polished sample or a polished
spec script
um and that um that you're submitting or
or somebody's reading or it doesn't
matter who's reading it it really
doesn't because once you're once you are
mincing who what eyes are on your script
you're in trouble right there
you you you you you need to convince
anybody and anyone that what you have is
as worth seeing turned into a movie
so what that means is you either you
have either have to
um knock them in the head
um punch them in the gut or kick them in
the balls
and and and and and and and and and and
and that's something that you have to be
doing in The Narrative of your story
um and and if you know you are doing
that with your story
you know you'll notice what I'm saying
here is like it's not just your script
it's your story because your script is a
artifice that starts to make someone
um believe that there are reading a a a
a story a a a a a potential movie
something that they get immersed in that
they get lost in
now if you're not taking them to that
place if you're not creating that
illusion with the words that you mind to
do it then you have lost from the get-go
from the beginning
so
that's if anything is what I imagine if
somebody has my uh my script in a pile
over the weekend and the thing is that
what what I enjoy about that thought or
that that metaphor
um is that you know I've you know had
experience with running the gauntlet of
that metaphor is like um
[Music]
is like you know you you know when you
like you're like oh hey like let me give
you that
Kunk that'll get your attention boom and
then you know you know you get the call
you get the phone calls like wow I love
your loved your love your screenplay wow
that was amazing that really hit me I
was I I read I read 200 scripts over the
last five days
you know
there's nothing more that you love to
hear than that you go like and yours got
my attention you know it's like it's
like that is that is like
you know that's the kind well 200 might
be a little but a little bit you know
people read a lot of scripts
um in the industry and and that's
because there's a lot of stuff out there
that you gotta fight to get through
um to um to to have people recognize
your talent as a storyteller
so you like I said you know you gotta
whack them in the head you know punch
them in the gut or kick them in the
balls
yeah okay
can you can you give me an example of a
movie that
it's gonna whack them or kick them in
the nether region that that for another
reason so sorry another reason in case
it's you know PG-13 whatever I'm
censoring myself
[Laughter]
can you give me an example of a movie
that if I saw an opening it would do
that and if that was the script I was
reading I would be feeling that to one
degree or another
okay
um let me see
um one that I can think of well you know
um just because we were just discussing
it
um
um Michael Clayton is great because you
have you have a lawyer who takes off his
clothes during a deaf position
you know immediately I'm like okay I'm
in
it doesn't happen every day you know
I'm in you know what I mean
this about I want to know I'm curious
you know right okay so like you know
that's one I'm always at a loss for like
pulling um examples for for some films
like you know at the at the drop of a
hat let me see if I can extrapolate I
can like if I go down the list of like
you know for me of um of Tony Gilroy
movies it's really actually not so hard
with him because like you can go to like
to The Bourne Supremacy which is amazing
opening one of the great openings where
like um you know
um there's a Chase
um and um they they find we're born is
um where he's hiding out
um with his girlfriend and his
girlfriend dies in the first in the
first 10 minutes I think of the film and
I'm like
and you're like the stakes are so high
at that point
um it's uh this is you know this is what
you have to do with your storytelling
most of the time now now what I mean by
that when I say like um
oh
um
um you know wax them in the head punch
someone in the gut or kick them in the
nether region so to speak
um is is is that it can be a slow burn
too it doesn't have to be immediate if
it's a slow burn in it and it hooks you
you'll notice that sooner or later it
will it it has you in its grips to the
point where you're like where it'll do
something that is um so enthralling that
it won't leave your memory that you
won't you just you won't forget it it
just won't go away
you know and and and and that is what
you're doing with storytelling if you if
you are under the um
if you under the notion or the idea or
the the misconception that you are you
are
trying to
um Express
um something that you feel is um
well for lack of a better term you know
I I think that that that that some
writers new writers
um they get caught up in these
masturbatory exercises of emulating you
know certain
um other writers and and filmmakers that
they really admire
and it's just an Indulgence because
they're just trying to piece together
the things that they that they like
thinking that that's going to make an
impression on the reader but that is not
going to do it you know what's going to
make the impression is someone getting
lost in what you're telling them you
know and and and and and the way that
you tell them um tell them it
um and if you get if you get caught up
in those kind of details you're gonna
you're gonna be in trouble you know
you're not your people are going to get
bored and they're going to shut your
script because what really happens
with readers what really happens with
Executives and producers and people that
have very busy schedules
is they take five pages of your script
and they read it and then they put it
down if it doesn't hook them
you'll be lucky actually if you get five
pages
you'll be lucky
so those five pages whatever you're
doing in those five pages
whether it's the way you've written that
description
whether the way it's the way that you've
delineated
um those characters
whether it's it's a passage of dialogue
they have to they they have to be firing
on all cylinders
or it's like
next becomes a drink coaster yeah next
next
yeah that's the way it works
can you give me an example and I'm
trying to come up with a euphemism for
the term that you use but of of a writer
who's stroking their own ego a master of
their domain as you so well they're
they're bad writers you know it's it's
like you you can't you can't take on you
can't take on someone someone who is
successful because more than likely
they're doing something right
do you know what I'm saying so so so uh
you you can't I I I can't cast
dispersions against anybody that's
successful at what they're doing because
they're doing something right
TN to get to get people's attention
so um
it's you know it's it it's simply just
that it's like
keep keep people turning the page you
know and um
and and and tell your story but you
gotta you gotta keep them excited or
they'll throw it away sometimes I've
gotten into the situation and this
happens a lot
where um where someone will say send me
send me a couple of screenplays send me
um send me three free scripts or
something like that right
now you have to be smart about that
all right
because
when you do that you go well maybe maybe
do you like this
maybe or maybe they won't like that and
maybe they'll like that over here all
right
so you send it
and the and and sometimes they'll go you
know what I I was reading I've been
reading uh pile of scripts
and you know
um one of your scripts you know it's I
just didn't really connect but the other
one oh
oh because you you you know what you're
doing that's the confidence I'm I'm
talking about you know what you're doing
it's like well maybe they're not this is
not the sort of thing that they're that
they're in that that's their oath but
maybe this over is like that's a little
conversely on the other side of that of
of this kind of subject matter
so so that's what the game is
that's what the the strategy is behind
the game the game is getting them hooked
just as you would be hooked if you were
in the theater
watching the story
all right because if it reaches that
stage like we said if you're we're
successful to get to that point
then you must be doing something right
you know it must be do even even the
even the the the the the the more
lackluster stories still
our stories
how did you figure out your voice I
yelped into the wind and
um no uh
you know what I I you know when you
asked me that question
immediately the first thing that popped
into my mind and it really has nothing
to do with anything we're discussing
um was
um
the first
few lines of James Joyce's portrait of
the Artist as a Young Man
and
what that story
and that book means as a
as a as a tale about
this this modernist Tale
that is descriptive of how an artist
reaches his voice
that is
descriptive in in the way that it tells
how that artist reaches his voice
because anybody familiar with portrait
of an of an artist knows that it is a
it starts with
these kind of weird little phonetics
because
he's like he's just a he's just a baby
and he like he's like looking out on a
pastor and he sees cows and he's like
Moo Cow and stuff like that and it's and
and then it slowly develops into what
becomes a language that starts to become
sophisticated which is uh the
um the is considered like
what people said was brilliant about
James Joyce and it is brilliant
um
also they said that James Joyce well
James Joyce apparently was a very
he was very very influenced it was like
he was the very first generation
of of
novelists that were were influenced by
cinema cinema had influence
on writing the novel
as opposed to
and that was early Cinema
um very early so now yeah because I just
got lost in thinking about portrait of
the artist it's such a good book
we'll put a link down
um it's um okay so how I figured it out
um I talked a little bit about that um
before and that that really was
um kind of discovering how to write in
these terse sentences I already had a um
a a
sense of how to write decent dialogue
um and um I was I I was just honing that
along with creating these little terse
um
bursts of uh of description to create
the scene structure
um
that was working for me
um simultaneously I learned how to
outline
now outlining for me at that time was
um something I I used a structure of 12
Beats
um I think it's a I think in the
beginning the way I I worked it out and
also the way I was taught because there
was various areas that I um I um I
picked up some of this the skill set
that I had I'd read
um of course the art of dramatic
um screenwriting I mean dramatic writing
um I also um was very fond of
um of some of David mamet's essays and
books
um I um I I took a couple courses here
and there and so I did distilled it down
to writing a premise or a log line
for the for the um the overall
um idea of what the story would be and
that that premise or log line has the um
is is elastic in itself meaning that it
it can evolve it can change over time
you can always return to it and augment
it in some way as you are going through
the writing process and then for each of
the 12 beats of my screenplay
um
so basically when I say 12 beats is if a
screenplay is technically 120 Pages
there's a beat for every 10 pages all
right
and then you're thinking of of the story
and we're talking the story now as an
EKG
all right so what I mean by an EKG and
you can also apply this to Christopher
vogler's ideas on the the hero's journey
as well the EKG is like you are you're
lifting off with your inciting incident
um the inciting incident
um technically should occur anywhere
from like the five page to to like well
in the old days it was like five pages
for to 30 page but like it's it's really
just five pages now you really don't go
farther than that
and then
um
and then what you do is you um you
plateau off as you get towards the um
towards the middle of the EKGs so that's
like
um page 60 and that means basically that
your characters or your protagonist is
um on his way to
um towards his journey and so that's
beat six
and then um on on beat nine
um you are um you are um you are coming
all the way down on your EKG
um you're spiking downward because they
are facing all their adversity and all
of their obstacles that they must
overcome that they may never they may
never recover from
and then if they do recover and they do
succeed and they win in the end then
that EKG comes all the way back up at
12. if they don't if they don't win then
that EKG comes all the way up at 11 and
then goes sharply down at 12.
so
that is
um that is basically
um the that 12 point beat
um outline now with the 12 point beat
outline each one of those beats one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve
um has its own premise so every 10 pages
or approximately 10 pages because you
don't have to adhere
um
strictly to 10 pages because you know
maybe you have a shorter script
um has its own log line so you go this
is when such and such happens
such and such occurs cause and effect to
cause and effect statement that is
something that is that has a whole
chapter in um loud Los hegres
um the um the the art of dramatic
writing is the cause and effect
statement that goes all the way back
that that can apply all the way back to
the Greeks
and he takes it there so
so
um you you do that
um for each one of those beats
um and then from each one of those um
log lines you use those as a basis to
to work on to script those 10 pages or
roughly those 10 pages and then if you
adhere to that
you'll you'll you'll probably get
yourself a um a first draft it may not
be much of a first draft but it'll be
something that you can you can rewrite
and that you can work on now that was my
process back in the early days
um
and that's how I I figured things out
um once once you're writing the second
draft once I was rewriting at that point
um that's where I start to apply a
little bit of those tricks a little bit
of the fun stuff
um
that's
that's a whole other
bit of tools and things like that
um there's there's there's refining that
goes in with that sort of thing
um
you want to look at your script as what
is necessary in the story
um and what and try to take out what is
not necessary now um
this is one thing that I do believe
many storytellers
um fail to do
and it doesn't make them bad
storytellers
it's just their choice but um some some
some storytellers
just overload their scenes
and they just want to do so much inside
of the scene
and it's not that you don't need to do
that to do a movie
to tell to tell uh um a story
um for the service of a screenplay that
is to be interpreted into a movie or a
film does not require it to be a play
[Laughter]
you know if you're going to be a play
you can make a play you know I write
plays myself as well I think that's fun
but it's not required it's a it's
something that you um you it's a it's a
story that you tell in pictures
um if I want to strike another analogy
um that analogy for me is that at a
certain point for me and this goes
towards the root of the question is that
when you get you you you you you you you
figure out your your voice it becomes a
lot like playing music
it's like you're not reading music
anymore
um you you while you play it you're just
kind of improvising a little bit
and you're you're just kind of like
going with the feel you know while
you're you know you're jamming or
whatever
and
um the classic example
um for me
um is um felonious Monk
because
the thing about felonious monk that I
loved that reminds me of screenwriting
is that
he has this syncopation
it sounds Ray Charles too it's very it's
also a great one
um it has a single patient
that it's not the it's not what he's
playing it's not the chord that he's
hitting you know it's what's between it
it's the stop it's in between it that
that that that is where you feel
the story he's telling in the music
and then the same thing I believe
applies towards towards a good
screenplay you know
um yeah yeah
so it's within the cut yeah yeah yeah I
think he said the other thing I I like
to talk about is telling the story in
the cut telling the story in the cut is
is simple
um it's it's a little simpler than than
I think a lot of people make it and
um I um people
um tell writers and they tell filmmakers
and they tell directors you know
um you know show not tell show not tell
show not tell show not tell and that can
be kind of really confusing because it's
like you listen to those words and
you're like okay what the hell does that
mean you know what does that mean really
show not tell okay
um how do you show a screenplay I don't
understand what that means you know it's
like it's like and so like when you're
you're a writer and you're like you're
hitting yourself with those words like I
don't get it uh uh I'm telling
intrinsically by writing you uh you know
so you can be really confusing but
but what it acts
is
tell your story in the cut because you
know that is where the story actually
lives it lives in between the
juxtaposition of two scenes it it lives
in the transition
of those two scenes so the period
between those two scenes is where all
the information of your story is
uploaded so all the exposition that you
need to make in your story can be
implied
it could be all implied
you don't actually have to say the
exposition
like like I would say like what
70 percent of your your Exposition does
not have to go into your script
it can be all in the in your cut
because all you have to do is like is is
set up a um a visual cue with an action
and then cut to the end result of that
action to the aftermath and just by
doing that just by putting one picture
here all right
and then putting the end result of that
picture right over here
you've downloaded your or you've
uploaded your Exposition done
you know
so like the example I use is like is is
the um is the girl like you know at the
at the bar
um at the at the hotel bar and the
bartender comes up to her and gives her
a drink and then signals towards a man
at the end of the bar who waves at her
because he sends her to drink and then
cut to later they're in the in the in a
hotel hallway stumbling into her hotel
suite kissing and we know what happens
you know we don't need to know what they
discussed at the bar we don't need to
know what their conversation was we
don't know need to know all the details
in between we we get it we get it and
it's it's a really really simple
technique and not and and and and
there are a lot of filmmakers
um and writers that don't Avail
themselves of it
um and there are a lot of writers that
do
um
number one on the list is Kenneth
Lonergan who is
a brilliant writer and
um he knows exactly how to do that
um
and
um yeah William Goldman also knew
exactly how to do that so but but yeah
it's um
yeah it's it's a simple thing you know
um
more people need to do it that's all
how did you get better at telling your
stories within the cut sometimes it was
hard one
um because
um
I had this tendency I think like a lot
of new Writers Do
to
want to fall in love with their language
and to hold like some kind of like
chunky like Diner scene with like you
know some interesting characters talking
and like throwing some colorful banter
back and forth and like oh how
interesting this is and when when when
I started to realize that it was
unnecessary and that Not only was it
unnecessary that it was it was um it was
shooting on me myself in the foot as far
as it as far as I'm grabbing the intent
the attention of readers
um it's not to say that those characters
may not have been doing or saying
anything that was
um interesting or fun or anything it was
dropping the ball
you know in the ball game as far as like
making making my work stand out for
others because essentially what I
learned is that and the the in the long
and short of it
readers aren't interested in
um your scene
they don't care about your scene
they care about the story you're telling
them that's what they care about
they don't care about your scene they
care about the story you're telling them
so if they fall in love with your story
they'll they'll they'll fall in love
with your script
they're not going to fall in love with
your scene you know they're they're not
in it to fall in love with your scene
you know so yeah
although there is something very
Charming about those Diner conversations
I can't I know I I enjoy seeing them you
know and then you've got Marge the
waitress all right what'll it be and
then you know then they she leaves and
then they're trying to like talk you
know so that she doesn't well that's a
whole other I mean that's a whole other
discussion it depends on where it is and
it depends on how you do that sort of
thing
um
um is is one thing and you know like for
example my my favorite my one of my
favorite Diner conversations of course
is because it's charged you charge a
scene you charge a scene by telling it
um by telling your story in the in in
Cuts all right by by loading
um your story like that
um heat yes excellent you you you you
you charge everything is very very
um sparse and very
um
it there's not much going on in heat
other than the the action
um the reactions
um the the setups for the heist it's it
it's very lean
um heat and then it gets to that Diner
scene between Pacino and um and De Niro
and it means everything that
conversation that conversation means
everything and that's how you load those
scenes
by by you know telling your story and
then you come to a scene where there is
you know more or less you know a
standoff if it's not a metaphorical
standoff
um it's not emotional standoff
um that's how you tell stories in
general
you know
um you can't have that standoff in every
scene of your script
otherwise you're confused about what
you're doing
sure and then keeping it lighter I the
80s 90s sing-along scene which I don't
know why they used for so long where
something's on the radio somebody turns
on a stereo and now the whole group's
singing together that seems to be lost
and I'm happy that that's the case you
know I don't I don't mind stuff like
that I don't I don't mind anything
that's experimental like that as long as
everything else is tight
you know
um you can do anything experimental but
if everything else is tight
it
it it'll it will um it will like rise to
the top okay
um I I I'm a I'm a personally you know I
mean it's it's not my favorite film okay
but I am a sucker for that
Hall and Oates scene in 500 Days
okay all right I am a sucker for that
seat because I've been that guy
okay
I I've walked out of that
swinging like that okay so I bid that
guy so I'm a sucker you know so I mean
like so if you do it right you know you
it it flies it flies
Big Bear Mountain
a weightlifting competition a stock
broker
Six Sisters
a plane crash
three pennies
gambling addiction
Friday at midnight
benefits of hard work
a man on the Run
and lastly this piece of dialogue
she ain't got time for that
again you don't have to use all 11.
okay
you know I've actually seen some some
movies about these things
all right
um
let's see
well you know
um
a lot of these are really classic
um and
I mean I'm almost inclined to like
string many of them together into like
like the strings some of them actually
into like one
um
but I don't think I'll do that
so like if I were to like take something
like uh like gambling addiction
um
I don't really think that that is a a
cause or an effect
um so to speak so you'd have to kind of
develop a cause and effect around it
so so
um you'd have like something like
um
a
uh
police officer
with
a gambling addiction
um
must
resolve
his debt
to
a
notorious
gangster okay
yeah
bye
murdering his partner hmm
the officer's partner or the gangster's
partner no he's uh uh the um the cops
partner oh wow okay
so what that what that that that that
creates is
um a cause and effect
um it's it's it's it's not the cause is
resolving is debt you know it's not it's
it it's not the gambling addiction the
gambling addiction is his uh I forget
what it's there's actually a name for it
I want to say misbehavior but I don't
think that's the correct one
um but um
it does not it it may predicate
um the cause but it's not a part of the
cause
um the effect is that he has to he has
to um to kill his partner which is kind
of
effed up
yeah so so yeah that's how that one
would work
um a man on the Run
there's so many men on the Run movies
things that always happens you know it's
like the big cliche
um
oh a man on the Run
um after
run after
a bank heist
um
after a bank heist
hmm
and this is not the officer no no this
is different I'm different okay
um
thank guys I'm stuck here after bank
heist
I want to say but I don't think it's
going to work
um
must
reconcile
this is Dopey
um with his daughter
ah
who ultimately
turns him in
okay
um it's getting interesting yeah let's
see
um let's take another one three Lucky
Pennies no or three pennies
retrieved from the bottom of the
fountain
um
bottom of a fountain
bestow
three wishes
that
reverse
into curses hmm
um
let's see
a weight lifting
competition
foreign
[Music]
okay
weightlifting competition
there's something there's another
element that needs to be in there
because there's no real cause
established a weightlifting competition
um
a weightlifting competition
that's because
it needs
a bodybuilder
entering
a weightlifting competition
competition
meets
his
lifelong Idol
foreign
[Music]
premise uh feelings
competing
against him
after learning
after learning so the drama of course
he's fighting cancer
what you want to do is you want to learn
to make that shorter
for your kids out there
already
um
Friday at midnight
a young
uh
what's he do
um
a young High School Dropout
in
the 1950s
discovers
his
his um
his purpose
Fridays
at midnight
drag racing
all right
the
local
streets
oh no dragging drag racing on the
off streets
of this small town
there you go
yeah let's see
um
what else we got here
let's tackle she got time for that
because that one's just weird
[Laughter]
that was just odd
so he dropped off of that
hey
a TV
comedian
is
haunted
by
the role
she played
on screen
and
is
becomes
violently
ill
every time
a fan
utters
her famous catchphrase
[Laughter]
catchphrase
actually I'm gonna write this one
she ain't got time for
you don't even know you know this is
this is like this got Netflix all over
it
yeah
you know HBO Max and Netflix they're
gonna be battling that over she ain't
got time for that
[Music]
let's see what else is here
a stockbroker
foreign
and High Finance
on Wall Street
starts
selling shares
man
we'll just go from really Fantastical
starts
showing shares
in the afterlife
done
um
Six Sisters
spurlonking
[Laughter]
um
I'm sorry what does that mean oh it's
like it's cave diving oh okay
sure where this was going okay
another region you want to keep it
Disney
Six Sisters spelunking okay
um
get
trapped
in
and
losing oxygen
come
to
the decision
of
who lives or dies before someone rescues
them
someone rescue
rescues them
foreign how many do you have left of our
11. one two
three wow I did all them great okay can
you combine the remaining three into one
log line
um yeah I'll try yeah okay
um
actually you know
this is
pretty set up for me right there to be
honest
um
good
this one it does have a Cause
um
in
in Big Bear Mountain
foreign
ers
of
a plane crash
pretty it's writing itself
[Laughter]
must
save
the injured
through we'll just make it simple
through the benefits
of hard work
and
cooperation
so which of which log line is your
favorite that you've created oh that's
that's easy
that one easy
um it's a TV comedian is haunted by
a TV comedian is haunted by the role she
played on screen and becomes violently
ill every time a fan utters her famous
catchphrase she ain't got time for that
that's a winner
and why do you why does that resonate so
much for you well it's not so much that
it resonates
um it's it's it that that not at all why
um the nature of a log line is is is a
couple of things and these many of these
if not all of these and I was having fun
um
um violate
um pretty much the strict rules of the
long line and and one of those is that
is brevity
a log line should be concise that one's
not so concise but it does the other
thing a long line should do it grabs
your attention
so the so
technically a log line is is something
that if you're over a conversation over
dinner
um you can say casually to your dinner
guest or to whoever it is or even if
you're just you're pitching it
um over dinner
and you can just let it roll off your
tongue and it have a sort of ring to it
you know and a ring and a varissa
military you know then then usually or
hopefully someone responds to it like oh
well that's nice well that's interesting
I'd like to see that you know it's it's
it's the thing that sort of makes you go
I want to know more
and that's really the the objective
that's the purpose of a log line because
it
I mean well okay I'm gonna I'm gonna
back that up too
the log line also helps you design your
screenplay
that is one that's an that's another
purpose you can use it for but at the
end of the day when you're done with
your screenplay and you've re you've
refined your log line and you make it
concise
you need to be able to give it to the
world and use it as a hook
so a lot of the log lines that you came
up with you said they were too long
especially the one that you really loved
that it it's got to be shorter so if we
were going to take let's say the log
line for Fargo I know you said you liked
the Coen Brothers work yeah or a serious
man or something like what what how
would we shorten that down because
because that would be hard a serious man
that would be kind of difficult to have
a shorter long line with that I don't
know there I mean if you look up if you
you you know there's there there are
smarter men than me that have
um defined the log lines for for those
films and you can look them up you can
Google them
um and they they're very brief actually
I've read one for a serious man and it's
uh it's it's it's it it is kind of brief
if you want to borrow the allegory from
something else to describe
like movies like that it's usually you
know it's not you don't have to reach
too far
um
um like um
you know
um a
you know a what is a serious man it's
like a cancer diagnosis leads to a
journey of Discovery for
um
um a man that often considered himself
invisible and now
um comes to comes to a sense of rebirth
you know I mean that's that it it's
pretty simple you know and and what it
is is like and if any writer or writer
who's a reader I would say is like when
they see a movie like a serious man or
they um are familiar with the script
serious man they'll go well this is just
um The Odyssey by Homer you know it's
pretty it's the same thing you know and
believe me the comb Brothers knew it was
the Odyssey by Homer as they were
writing it
um it's um
it's kind of a blatant
who was PSY and the artist
I don't know but I think maybe the the I
would say he was the Cyclops
um
they've returned to the Odyssey
um again and again the odd they actually
did an explicit interpretation of the
Odyssey with Oh Brother Where out there
um or Brother Where Art Thou is the
Odyssey beat by beat
um
um remember
um John Goodman
um at the tree with the patch on his eye
he is the Cyclops
um so
[Music]
um
so yeah yeah
and so with this what would be the title
for this comedian who who's really just
repulsed by this famous role that she's
known for and all the fans want to
repeat it to her what would you call it
oh uh well it's in the it's in the log
line it's the it's the capture phrase
she ain't got time for that okay
and why why does that make her ill why
why does she not like that role
well it makes her violently ill
um um like physically
in in in the way I would foresee it so
like
um she would have actual uh physical
reaction she would convulse she would
she would should and it would become
progressively worse and and manifest
itself and probably some very
um gruesome strange way
um and and uh take it to its to it it's
inexorable extreme
so have fun with it it's a it's a very
humorous
um
premise and I I I enjoyed that I I
rarely actually write things like that
but I also but I do find those kind of
things entertaining and you know what I
end up doing is usually this is like um
I um I take things like that and I I
make them quite serious along the way
you know that's why I like the cone
brothers because you know they they're
they're they're they're
satiris in a serious way quite often
do you feel movies today are less
entertaining than they used to be
yes
that's absolutely
um
uh reason why is because I think we're
in a fallow period
um for movie making and I think people
are afraid of taking risks and
I think
that a lot of movies are cookie cutter
and because of the way that the business
is structured right now
um it's a it's it's not allowing for a
lot of new talent to emerge and
and receive the kind of attention that
it should
um I think that
um
there's periods where the pendulum
swings on that
and that the opposite is the case but
right now we're in one of those follow
periods and hopefully it will swing in
the other direction
um in the in the 90s we had a very great
night amazing era I think it lasts a
little bit into the odds but after that
it just you know went back to to to to
to to you know mostly Studio fair I have
nothing against Studio films by the way
I think they're fine and they're fun but
you need to have other stuff too
um and we don't have enough of the other
stuff
um 70s we had a lot of that other stuff
and uh
and now it's just another one of those
periods where we just don't have a lot
of that other stuff
why do you think that is
well it's um it's just kind of the way
the business is is has been structured
um and
um it's it's it's kind of like we had a
new influx of um
of
of people
um in to the system
um in the 90s from you know new kinds of
producers new kinds of
um Executives so that there's there is a
legitimacy that
um that independent filmmaking received
in which it was actually
um actually was if not Prestige it it
was given consideration as far as being
having money making possibilities
and some of those films did make money
um but
um but now the party is over
um
the the the the movies that they that
they acquire at places like can and
Sundance are already set up
you know it's like you don't you don't
get in there on a lark like you used to
you're not you're not you can't be OS
Anderson you can't be a a Kevin Smith
out of the blue you can't be you know
you you're you know you're already
you're already
um
you're already fully funded and backed
by
um some kind of
um
corporate arm
that allows you those kind of
opportunities
and um
that's just the case there's
once again I have no judgment over those
things it's just just the way it is
um I'm hoping that because of the
streaming territory that we're in now
that sort of allows a little more
wriggle room for that
for that to see the light of day in
which there can be new kind of new kind
of talent
taking advantage of those sources but
uh I don't see where the evidence is of
it yet you know
hopefully there will be
do you think filmmakers are forcing a
message in today's films
um I don't think that um
I don't think that there's
okay
um that's a complicated question
um and I'm going to like answer it like
this
um
I enjoy watching Martin Scorsese movies
um and I really enjoyed watching the
Irishman because I thought it was a
great
um great historical
um
road map and it had a a greater message
about the the the American story
and
um I am so glad that that someone like
that even though he has to fight for it
given his status as a filmmaker that
someone like that has the luxury to to
um to have that kind of message that he
can put forth in the in his films
um
but not everybody has that luxury
and not everybody has that kind of
opportunity
and certainly
um the the the the the new Martin
scorses the young Martin scorses he's
the female Martin Scorsese the black
Martin Scorsese the Asian Martin
Scorsese
aren't getting that opportunity
and
um because they all have
statements that they want to make about
America
[Laughter]
and um and those aren't those aren't
salable and and today's market you know
um those aren't um
those aren't things that people want to
um to necessarily
um finance and it is what it is now I'm
not saying that you know finances are
bad or or or
um or Studios or bed and they're they're
the boogeyman or anything like that I
think that's really uh
a a horrible attitude to possess
um
um I think there's a lot of filmmakers
that are proponents of a sort of
victim-like stance but
that does not negate the fact
that the current ERA we're in
is not looking for a new voice
vigorously
so the Martin Scorsese that was able to
tell the Irishman
how different was that person that told
the story of Taxi Driver traffic I I
really don't think
um um um
much of a difference I mean I think it's
the same Spirit you know I think he's a
he's a he's an incredible filmmaker and
he's he's he's evolved oh yes yes but uh
I don't think he is much different but
he was he he was able to solidify
reputation
um and I believe it was 1978.
that the taxi driver came oh this is 76
76 or 78 I think it was 76. it seems
like it was earlier yeah I'm not sure
though but yeah
um yeah so
um it was he was able to settle a
reputation then
um
and he could he could go on and and and
continue to make personal uh movies like
that I mean the same thing can can be
said for a lot of people in that Echelon
you know the same thing can be said for
for Spike Lee you know um but even so
you know Spike Lee has to fight to get
financing because he's making movies
that are about messages
he's got he's trying to tell he's got a
message behind a story you know
um I remember years ago when he was
still alive
um
I was I was watching a panel on um on
Robert Altman
and and he said Robert Altman said you
know
it's like
someone asked him like in the panel like
how do you get financing for your film
and he's like
I don't know I I find it just I I find
it just as hard to get financing as I
think any young filmmaker would this was
like around 2000 he said this and I and
I tended to believe him you know
um
you know you you're you're you're you're
you're an older man you know who's
trying to go out there and get financing
to make a movie that says something
and people aren't looking to to do that
and today
you know you we know what kind of movies
get made you know it's like you know
you're not they don't want it you know
and it's understandable
it's a it's a business you know it's a
it's it's it's it's a business they're
looking for a return and that's the
other thing that I think that um writers
should be very aware of that
what they are in is a business now you
can consider yourself an artist and
that's absolutely fine I'm in fact I'm a
proponent for that I consider myself an
artist
be an artist you know if that's what you
want to be be an artist but don't get
mad
if you realize you're in a business
[Laughter]
because that's what it is
you know it's they're they're out there
to make money they're not out there to
make art you're out there to make art
they're out there to make money
you know so yeah do you feel like that's
the real um test of how long you want to
stay in this business or attempt to stay
in it is to realize that well I mean
I think you're you know you realize what
you do
as a writer you know you um you
understand where your lane is so to
speak and that's not to say that you
limit yourself to um to a track it's to
say that you are content
um and you you you're nourishing
um your creativity and and wherever it
is that you track
um for like example for myself
um I write I write screenplays and I
also write plays
you know and I enjoy writing plays a
great deal I enjoy this theater I enjoy
that experience you know I enjoy working
with actors in the terms of stage
um
but and and and and and and and and
working and and staging the work and and
and and and and and and and seeing it
come alive
in a room full of people where it's not
um projected on a screen it's a whole
other experience
but you know this is the thing you know
this is all under the O of oh this is
what I do as a writer it's not under the
ove of what I do as a screenwriter
um so
I at any one point or time you know I
can take my frustrations
to writing a play and go down the street
get some friends together go into a
theater and say hey let's hear this
let's hear this out loud
you know so I mean
that's that's my feeling on it and and
there's plenty of other writers that
that that do the same thing you know
we've got we've got
um
um writers that that cross both Fields
Aaron Sorkin Tracy Letts David Mamet
Susie Lori Parks these are all
um um playwrights and screenwriters
um ask them what they do
Aaron sorkin's never going to say oh I'm
a screaming there it's like it's gonna
go I'm a writer I write that's what I do
you know Sam can be said for for other
people that cross
um I'm I'm very you know the other
mediums of writing Stephen King Stephen
King's not gonna say yeah I'm a
screenwriter
same again it's like I'm a writer
Stephen King's bigger than than any one
movie so yeah
for a writer was never submitted to The
Blacklist how does that work the
Blacklist
um I think it's important to to point
out is
um you um you upload a screenplay
to their website
um and the website more or less is a
collection of screenplays that are
written by anybody anybody can upload a
screenplay or a TV pilot
um to The Blacklist it doesn't doesn't
matter who you are where you are in the
world you can go ahead and do so
um those scripts are evaluated now the
the one thing is though um you're going
to be paying a monthly fee and that is
um I think the monthly fee is thirty
dollars for for that script to be hosted
on the site and for each evaluation you
must pay
um a 75 dollar fee
now if you have the money to do that
which for some that can be a little
tight to afford
but if you have the money to do that
it's very much worth the while because
the Blacklist is probably the main
um it's the Central Access that you will
have to the the the film industry on
these days specifically if you're not in
Hollywood and you don't have an agent or
some kind of representation that can
submit your work and get you meetings if
you don't have any access to
um
a
representation
agent or a manager that can submit your
scripts or get you meetings
so it's worthwhile to
to post your script on The Blacklist the
other thing that's really wonderful
about The Blacklist is that the readers
there provide coverage for your scripts
um
now this coverage is is good in and of
itself I mean of of
um of its own to to promote
um the what what a concise understanding
is of your story
um on your on your Blacklist page but it
also is a great tool for you to know
where the flaws are in your script
so you can you can use it as a balance
sheet as to where you need to
um fix areas that may not be
communicating well
um if you if you are a new writer and
you are you're you have trouble taking
criticism critique
or receiving critique it's a great it's
a great
um
baptism by fire this is the the other
thing
um in regards to the Blacklist this is
um invaluable
um
as you develop your skills as a writer
you have for you right there at your
disposal
a barometer through which you can
you can you can understand how how
strong your work is
so if you are getting recognition on The
Blacklist and and certainly if you're
getting recognition regularly on The
Blacklist
um you you know that you're ready to um
to go out into
um into the field or to March out into
the field so to speak so if you are
trepidatious about a screenplay that um
that you are going to submit to an agent
or a producer if you
um are a little
um unsure or uncertain about something
that you want to pass on for
consideration to to anybody
try and see if uh you can pass mustard
on The Blacklist
um see if um that script um can get get
you a score of an eight or above if you
are getting an eight or above score on
The Blacklist then I think you can be
entirely confident that you um that your
script has has legs at that point
um so I think that that
um that that's what also makes it a
wonderful tool
um
it's
a very good site
um
because what it does is it um it Bridges
the Gap
um between the industry and
um and pretty much anybody
um anywhere it doesn't it doesn't
exclude
um you out of the process whoever you
are and wherever you are
um before on The Blacklist existed
we had this um this Arcane version of
that and that simply meant that you had
to be somewhat in the know or working
at some in some strata of the industry
to be able to um get your scripts read
by a reader at a production company or
an agency or what have you
instead now you can just go online
um pay the fees and have a reader
produce coverage for you that way
in the old days in fact
you know they they sometimes if you were
submitting your script to a producer
they'd asked to see your coverage
instead of your script itself so that
they could get an overview of your
script and you go oh well I have some
coverage here and let me let me send
that on on to you you can have a look
um here on on The Blacklist they can
simply go on to The Blacklist read your
coverage and then download your script
so it's great and and and and and and
Franklin Leonard is a he's a really
um really really really really
fascinating
inspiring character
um with what he's done here with his um
with his website and also his um his um
his advocacy and support of people in
all areas of the writing field and his
um his strong stance on inclusion so so
um I'm I I can't say anything but good
things about him and his and what he's
done for for the community
but what kind of feedback have you
gotten on some of your work that's made
it onto the Blacklist
well uh I I've I've I've been lucky
enough to score high
um a couple times yeah
um
that's I've I've had some good feedback
um I think
I think that
um
as a writer you you it's incumbent upon
you to run that Gauntlet that you need
to you need to go on there and score
high on The Blacklist you I mean this is
this is where this is where my my my
pride will come out or let's say my ego
as a writer
um where is like I need to knock I need
to I need to see this this this script
this story whatever knock it out the
park somewhere so it's it's got to knock
it out the park on The Blacklist it's
got to knock it out the park on on the
on a on a spot on the Nichols Fellowship
it's got to knock it out the park on on
say Austin I've never placed on Austin
but I'm just going to say that it's got
to knock it out somewhere
um once it's done that then I'm like
okay well I'm pretty sure it's a good
script
you know or I'm pretty sure it um it
will impress somebody somewhere
so
um these are our tools today that we
have
um at our disposal at our fingertips
literally in front of us on our screens
that we can use as parameters for how
good our work is
um so you know they should be used you
know you should use them
um and not be not be afraid you know
um
it's um I know it it can be really
daunting to to receive criticism and to
um allow others to look at your work but
this is the thing
um is that
first of all you learn not to take um
criticism personally
um that it doesn't mean that you should
necessarily change anything that you're
doing
it
it only offers you one thing
it's perspective
that's it
criticism gives you perspective yeah now
what does that mean
well what that means is
that I can judge the distance
between what I'm going for and what
lands
that's what that means
so
if I'm if I'm hitting
with something that where I I was going
for a Target
and I know it's hitting
and I'm getting that
feedback
from somewhere else an objective Source
I'm getting that feedback
then I know I'm on to something
you know
um that that's perspective
um if you if you're getting something
that's a little off to the side if
someone's going I'm seeing this as
something else is someone's
misunderstanding it entirely
then you you might want to step back and
adjust
you might want to go oh okay well I'm
gonna I'm gonna I'm Gonna Change how
this um you know how the second act sort
of um moves right here or I'm going to
adjust you know this aspect about the
Beast story or I'm going to
um
um give this character a um you know a
long lost sister
you know it's
it's convenient can be the difference
between a good script
and a great script
perspective will give you that
perspective will imbue you with that
and when you have that experience
you never you never take criticism
personally
in fact you invited and you want to know
and you're curious about people's
criticism even if they if if they're not
even if they're
they're they are to a certain degree
misguided criticism
even misguided criticism can Enlighten
you as a writer
and make you a better writer
say I'm a screenwriter and I upload my
script to The Blacklist and I pay my 75
dollars am I just getting a one-time
feedback some notes or is that script
now accessible to anybody yes
um that is the case
um anybody can read the script on The
Blacklist
um
what's cool about that is that
um the the designated readers that you
um that you pay for or hire to read your
scripts
um will will provide you with feedback
but also the people that or the industry
folks that go on there and may stumble
across your script or see your log line
and just appreciate your long line also
have the option to um to download your
script
and they also have the option to offer
you coverage
so
um that's a cool thing I think it's rare
that that ever happens because I've
never received coverage from someone
that have just has just been perusing my
script or just downloading it
um um off of the off The Blacklist now
more than likely what does happen though
is that you you you get a high score on
The Blacklist and that's when you
actually get attention from um from from
industry readers
um and they'll and they'll download your
script
um
in numbers
but um
but and that's what you want that's what
you want to try and do
um you want to
you know it it can you know let me tell
you it can be expensive
um if you're paying 75 pop as you revise
your script to try and make it better
and better so you get some kind of
attention you know that can add up after
some time but if you do
um I'm I'm you score High
um
you know that can be offset by the fact
that you're going to have you know
a lot of a lot of people downloading
your script
because I just said did you get any
feedback and you said you you scored
High
um I don't know if we went into if there
was any negative feedback and maybe we
don't want to go there or well yeah I
mean
yeah there's negative feedback but that
but that's but that's a part of what
what screenwriting is you know you need
to get negative feedback at some point
you know you're not
if
you someone is not going to like
something that you've written somewhere
you know for some reason the what you
need to know is why
that's that that's it you know you need
to know is why there
um there's a there's a meme that's
circulating right now
that by um by um
um that's that features um Jordan peel
and Jordan peel says you know
um
you know how you handle criticism
this is how you handle criticism
uh when I have a screenplay and I send
it out there and someone says
you know there's a scene in there it's
just way too violent you know I just it
it took me out of the screenplay
you know I I think you should do
something about that
he's like I don't go home and take that
scene out of the screenplay no what I do
is I go back and I work on that
screenplay and find the thread that
substantiates that violence
and I and I make that I I I express that
in a more succinct and better way that's
that that that's you know that's what he
says and I'm paraphrasing but but that's
basically what he is um is expressing
and
um you know that's my my exact same
attitude
you know negative negative feedback
sometimes it's your best feedback
sometimes it gives you the best you get
breakthroughs you know from negative
feedback yes absolutely
so I have a little bit of a writing
challenge we can try and I'm hoping you
can um help me to make this small bit of
information better I'm going to read it
to you so my story is about a young
writer trying to break through whatever
breakthrough means we'll call him Joe
and he's a good guy from a small town
his parents were hippie artists not a
lot of money but they supported his move
to Los Angeles and so while riding
during the day and very tired at night
from these humbling like grunt jobs Joe
meets someone who decides to take him
under his wing and it's a producer who
says you know what I like your work
and needs some Polish but I'm going to
help you
and so the young writer Joe is just like
wow this is my dream come true I call my
parents and they say we're so proud of
you we always knew you'd succeed and
then after about a year reality sets in
for Joe
and Joe starts to see that he's being
used and sometimes abused and this
producer not only steals Joe's ideas but
he has Joe do a lot of his personal
Dirty Work like uh go spy on his tenants
go spy on his wife and also pick up his
dry cleaning
um and then he he has him writes skating
reviews on a former Nemesis and he takes
those reviews and he uses them as an his
own because he used to be in a literary
world so he has Joe you know review some
of this other person's work and then
writes these these reviews and then he
publishes them as his own so
how could we clean this up this is about
like a story of a young writer who's
who's really hungry to be in the
business but he starts to see wait a
minute
I'm in a bad element right here I'm in a
bad way
for those of you who have worked in the
agency world this is the story of an
assistant
okay is that the log line that's the
long line no it is that's what it is
it's the story of an assistant
and it's the tame version oh okay wow
all right
okay so mine's for all Auditors okay
great no it's true actually
um um you know actually some you know
you know some insistence would be like
oh no it's much worse than that uh but
um
yeah no so what's the what what's the
purpose of this the purpose is to show
the good guy with a good heart whose
parents believed in him comes here and
finds that his goodness is taken
advantage of
okay and and and
my reflection on this is how can I clean
it up to tell the story better because
it's not just the idea but it's it's how
I'm telling it
well it's first of all you have to
shorten the shorten how you say it
um you have to you have to turn it into
a a concise bit of wording it has to
become a log line or a premise it has to
be something that you can issue briefly
um that um has a bit of a
snap to a bit of a hook uh something
that pulls you in
so um that is number one and so not to
say that it doesn't have it
but you have to you have to find it in
there you know a story
is
um is sometimes like um like a block of
marble
and and and you're the Sculptor
and you have to you have to find the
form in the marble
what you have right now is marble
and you need to find the form
um
um Michelangelo used to say
um I don't know if you've ever been to
Italy but it's one of the most beautiful
things you've ever seen is the David
um but um Michelangelo used to say that
he would look at the um the block of
marble and he could see inside of it to
form
and and it's proven that he he did
because
um at the Academia where the um where
the um the David sits it's flanked on
both sides by um by his sculptures known
as the slaves
and the slaves were unfinished because
um I think he it was towards the towards
the end of his life so
um Michelangelo basically
um chiseled straight in to the marble
towards the form
he didn't like like other other
sculptors Whittle all the way around the
marble Farm to get to the form he went
right to it so he'd be an arm sticking
out of the block there'd be a leg
partially in the block and the rest
would be all just raw marble so
that's what you got there is a bunch of
raw marble
um and you have to get to the form
that's inside and the form would be your
The Germ the absolute germ of your story
The Log line
okay so maybe the long line it since too
long but it could be a premise you know
it could be it's a long line it would
just be one sentence correct yeah
technically it's it's it's it's one
sentence sure or so it one or two
sentences okay so then Joe Young writer
finds out that goodness isn't always
rewarded in entertainment
that's a little broad
um it's it's it um
um Joe um
a young writer uh
is enthralled
by a mentor
in the Hollywood
industry
um
and moves
to Los Angeles to find
um success
and instead
becomes
um and it
is enslaved
to a powerful man that's more long
launch of of what you're looking for I I
tweak it a little bit more make it a
little a little better around there but
yeah that's what you'd be looking for
okay and and Joe who would he have as
sort of his
supporting character so we have this
producer who's like the Nemesis in some
ways and then would he have a roommate
how can we make Joe his dialogue was
someone to actually tell them about
what's happening who would Joe be
bouncing ideas off of
in this story
I don't know you you were telling me the
story so who do you think Joe would be
bouncing the ideas off of it sounds like
you think there would be a roommate or
there could be a coffee girl oh sorry
you know yeah there could be a coffee
girl
um you know and
Joe could could be going through a lot
of things I mean the question is who is
Joe and who is Joe you know why is Joe
you know you know
um what what is what what what really
motivates Joe you know that all tells
you a lot of things as well
you know
um
you know that you don't you don't need
to have
um
attendant cliches
um to to make any kind of story
um in fact avoiding them
um informs who informs a very sort of
often often a unique way of subverting
them
um avoiding them
um it allows you to go down at
idiosyncratic Road
where you start to come up with some
really original stuff
you know
um so you you know sometimes you want to
get around that it's like what if what
what why is it why is it a coffee girl
you know what if he's gay
that's true coffee boys you know what if
it's a yeah well it's a coffee coffee
Point
um you know
um you know roommate roommate why is he
what if he lives you know
what if he lives with the with the with
the producer what if he you know lives
in the producers
um garage he makes him live in the
garage you know
um what if he sleeps in his car what if
he sleeps in his car
now now if something's visually now I'm
starting to think what if he sleeps in
his car
you know
um lots of lots of young people come out
to places and you know they're they're
poor and they you know and and they have
to they have to sleep in their car
that's something I read about that's
something I hear about on NPR you know
um or the crummy weekly hotel yeah yeah
exactly exactly there's there's all
these other things you roads you can go
down
to to avoid those tropes
um and and it's good that you do because
you're going to get a more original
piece of work out of it
okay so I see yes so the cliche young
writer with the the proud parents back
home that maybe that that's that's
boring okay so then what if
we talked about what if the dad had a
gambling addiction and he gambled away
his college
tuition and so he wasn't able to get a
creative writing degree so he comes here
to LA
and it's not a coffee girl what if it's
someone who does drag at night at a club
okay and basically tells them the real
deal and has no we'll just tell him how
it is and he he trusts that person
because they don't want anything from
him okay so then um he basically says
you know the the let's say the drag is
Terry by night and then Terence by day
and then so so make it interesting like
just not the typical that's beginning to
be something I want to see or read okay
okay you see what I'm saying right
you're doing it you're you're doing it
right now you're going down those
off-roads
and it's starting to make me curious to
the point where like oh that's something
I haven't seen before I'm interested in
seeing or reading it
here's a here's a great
um test of of of writing something or
anything for any writer and it's it's a
simple one it's like write what you want
to see you know write the thing that
you've never seen before that you're
like oh I really like to see someone
make a movie about that what what an
idea
you know what you know what a novel idea
I'll write the thing that's never been
done that I always wanted to see done
so then I have to ask what happens to
Joe and how does he ultimately reconcile
with that job or leave it
and and then I have to plan out does he
quit does he get fired does something
happen to the producer does the producer
get arrested because maybe the producer
had
um a shady business on the side that no
one knew about
maybe he was involved in Auto uh he was
part of a ring of uh automobile scams so
he was in on it with doctors lawyers you
know workers comp all this stuff so he's
in on this and that's how he was really
making his money and that's how he's
funding the movies
and then he gets arrested and there's a
padlock on the house and the garage and
Joe's stuff is inside he's got to get it
out
so the sheriff has to come and let him
in
and then he goes back home
well yeah you could do that you could do
that okay you could do that as long as
it's organic as long as you feel that
it's organic and what you're telling me
sounds fairly organic
but um if it's not organic if anything
happens
that
does not seem organic to you as the
writer
um you should run from screaming you
know
in a run just run screaming from
anything that doesn't feel
um organic and natural to the characters
this is something we haven't talked
about is character is
that your character and what you've done
is you built up a character a character
profile more so than a long line or a
premise and
um and through that character profile
you have you have um
you have
um used that as a template to draw out
what potential actions would occur given
that situation
so
um so now we since we know who Joe's
character is you know
um we we get a sense of how that will
play out character is a very very funny
thing it's very very funny
and the reason why it's funny
is because it's prescient it's it's it's
a
um it's a
it's a it's a cute little tool because
it it
strings you along with like oh this is
the you know like you know it's not
going to go where you think it is but in
a way it always will
so it's a it's this little trick it's
like it's like it like gives you enough
bread crumbs to go okay it's gonna go
exactly where you think it is you know
but it you know it's gonna look like it
doesn't
you know
and that's what you do with character
um you um
you you you you set you set up
um the reader or the audience
um based upon the person's Behavior this
also works in tandem with um with
telling your story in the cut and
loading up your Exposition and um
between those cuts because if you're if
if if if if you show the behavior of
your character for example
and um you'll see this and stuff like
Lonergan does this did this in in
Manchester by the sea it's like uh if
you you know I go into a bar and
um and I get into a brawl
you know every time I'm gonna go into a
bar in this movie you don't even have to
see me in the bar
you know
um you know there's going to be a brawl
happening
you know
so so so
that
that's the sort of thing
um that you can do with character that
is um that is really really fun
um and is really really rich
um
um yeah yeah that's basically that I
feel like my character Joe is too much
he's too much of a good guy like he
needs some kind of Quirk or
idiosyncrasies he's too like he's
surrounded by interesting characters but
why would he stay in that situation I
feel like he's too flat so I feel like I
don't know who Joe is
he's just like this guy that's
surrounded by all these interesting
people okay who is Joe then that's what
I'm trying to figure out so so Joe
maybe okay his dad had this gambling
addiction he found out that his college
education was gone so well if if his dad
had a gambling addiction you know well
he has to he has to have some you know
some serious resentments you know about
that you know and and those resentments
probably manifest themselves from some
kind of problem of his own
um um addicts have a tendency to Tibet
to beget addicts
um and certainly have a tendency to
beget addicts and and the terms of
Storytelling so
um you know that's a very easy one to
Target you can there's a ton of things
you can choose from other psychological
issues
um it could be it could be alcohol he
could be a cutter he could it could be
numerous things that you can use as um
as tools you know right so Joe's not
just gonna come out of the womb perfect
then from well you no he wouldn't no he
wouldn't come out of that perfect
because he's you know he's gonna he's
gonna be resentful of his dad you know
um there there's you know there there
was a that dysfunction in this family is
going to be manifesting him even if it
is in even if it appears to be um
positive on the surface
um the that's always fun to do is to do
that little ironic thing with a
character where they
um where the
um the negative aspect of that character
looks like it's positive at first but
it's actually when taken to an extreme
it's negative
would you mind giving me an example
Harrison Ford mosquito Coast
so it looks as a positive where he he's
a he's a good fought protective father
but instead he takes his his family to
some like remote location and like puts
them through hell
you know you there's there's
you can take things that are good and
you can make them
at their at an extreme bad
um at any time
okay so then maybe the movie opens with
he and his dad
um betting on football games and it's a
father-son bonding and you think wow
they have such a great relationship but
then you realize
that some serious issues are happening
he's owed money he has a bookie that he
owes money to and it's just it's getting
out of control but you don't see that at
first you just see this father and son
watching these games and you think wow
that's really neat like they have this
close relationship yeah yeah and and and
and and and and and and and and and and
to a certain extent his father can be a
good father sure he could be a good
father but still be you know this kind
of loser you know
um there's tons of there's tons of
humans like that sure male or female
yeah and so then I'm trying to think
though how Joe would be scarred from
that but
um
yeah yeah that I think that's where my
trouble lies with this character is Joe
is too perfect surrounded by some people
that they're not damaged maybe they're
just very interesting people and I've
got to make Joe
not so one-dimensional
I think that's my problem is that
everyone else is more lively than the
protagonist
yeah yeah or
you can do some crazy stuff let's hear
it well I mean like
um what I mean by that is is that
um there there's there's other areas
that you can go
um you can go you can go down the line
like you're suggesting or you can start
to get meta with your character
um you can
um you can you can trade off your
character with other characters in your
story you can you can make it appear to
be about Joe and then it actually starts
to turn to be about somebody else in the
story
um sometimes sometimes like the Cohn
Brothers will give equal parity to some
characters and you'll go like I thought
the story was about this guy and why is
it now about this guy and and and and
and and and and and and
that's because they're Adept at pulling
that off you know not ever I wouldn't
suggest that a new writer should should
go out there out the gate and try things
like that but
you can do stuff like that
um it it's it's you know the this don't
you know you should if you are if you
are writing and you're having fun and
you're in the zone so to speak
um you shouldn't you shouldn't be
limiting yourself
um on ways that you can tell the story
if the story wants to go there if it's
organic
um if the story doesn't want to go there
then you don't go there
hmm that's interesting
yeah I think I really need to rework
this character because it's not I'm not
clear on who he is I feel like I'm clear
on some of the people around him
and
he's not
damaged enough or fully formed see well
well you know what would you do in this
case so once again have you written a
screenplay before I have not no okay so
so how would you approach writing this
well think I would try to outline it
okay I would maybe do
um I know what's been popular is this 24
I think it was Adam Skelter talked about
he had a teacher that did the 24 plot
points or whatever 24 24 beats or
whatever
um which is the same as 12. that's 12.
okay all right it's just doubled yeah
but and so I'm gonna have the opening
um of maybe on the couch and so all
right we got the you know the popcorn
and all the stuff for the game or
whatever maybe maybe they're drinking
together
um Joe's over 21
um and uh it looks like they have this
great moment so I'm gonna I'm gonna go
from there from that number one opening
and start
um and then we're gonna see some stuff
unravel at home maybe some yelling with
the mom
um and then
you know the the hard discussion about
I'm sorry
um
you're not going to be able to get to
yeah but after you're done with all that
um you're you know and you get all those
those points in there
um you're gonna you're gonna write it
right
sure in in screenplay format yeah okay
so I may have screenwriting software
okay and then when you're when you're
done writing it you're going to have
hopefully something that's going to be
around like 80 to 120 pages right okay
okay
then then once you have that 80 to a one
120 Pages the whole world changes
and I don't mean just like I don't mean
like you know necessarily the world of
script I mean your world
um because you are going to come and
look at that script with new eyes
and um and and and the new eyes that you
bring to that script is going to um is
is going to have a profound effect on on
your protagonist and that main character
none of every anything that you um
that you come out with as a as an idea
for like an outline
um or thought like that is going to is
going to magically crystallize into the
exact thing that you want
um what happens at least to me
um
quite often is that
um I'll start off with a vision of what
I'm going for
and then along the way that vision
changes and then towards the end it
really starts to really dovetail towards
the vision the original Vision but not
how I've expected never how I expect it
it dovetails towards the original Vision
but never down the road I expect it to
get
that's when I know that it's organic
because
I will sit there and I'll go like you
know what
this is what I want to do you this is
what new writers have to learn how to do
to make the Sophie's choice between what
you want to do and what's best to do for
your script
you know you might sit there and go like
you know what I really want to do this
because this is how I thought of it
no no that's not best to do for your
script what's best to do for your script
is this over here
because it's where your characters want
to go it's where your story wants to go
so you need to go in that direction
and you keep going into that direction
until it all falls into place
that's the way it works it doesn't work
any other way you know
um
and I would defy any any
um successful writer to
um to to um to say to say anything
otherwise about that experience
um
it happens like that it's like you're
like wow it all worked out in the end
you know
um but
never to a t but you have going on up
here
okay so I won't really know what I'm
working with until I take those 24
points and then I put them in screenplay
format write anything from 80 to 110
Pages or thereabouts and then maybe wait
on it a week or so
and then I really am working with the
beginning of the marble that's right
okay that's right
um
Ernest Hemingway
had a famous phrase
um
and um I'm gonna I'm going to I'm going
to use the um the um
the sanitary version
what is that
every first draft is crap okay okay okay
or poop right yeah keep it yeah every
first draft is poop okay good okay
and that that is a perennial it'll never
go away
from for time and memoriam for everybody
you know every first draft is poop even
if you think you're like oh this is
great no it's poop
You Know You're Gonna Come Back
and you're gonna you're gonna look at it
and it's going to come together the
other thing about that is
and this is this is this is something
every writer should know really at the
end of the day
um with with my familiarity with the
process and with all the writers that
I've known on so many levels
um successful otherwise and everything
there's no such thing as a finished
screenplay
that Medium
never is complete
you may think it's complete
it's never complete
a screenplay is finished
when the director calls action
that's when it's finished
there's no there's no designated finish
to a screenplay and if a writer ever
takes that for granted
it's they're they're not doing their job
writers should always be ready to come
up to bat and say I can make it better
or I can I can do this I can like
communicate this better I can do if
you're if
you're like on set
and the uh and and the director is um is
shooting the film and and he says you
know what
tomorrow I'm about to shoot these like
five pages
I I I'm not feeling it and the
producer's not feeling it
can you go back and rewrite them you're
going to go back and rewrite them you're
not going to say I'm done
okay you're not gonna go oh no it's
finished it's you know David Fincher
it's finished
David Fincher
I mean yeah that's all you that's all
you get out of me
you're not going to do that
you're gonna you're gonna go you're
gonna go home at night and you're gonna
rewrite those five pages for David
Fincher and you're gonna bring them the
next day and that's how it's going to go
down so yeah
there's no such thing as a finished
screenplay okay
and so is it is it when the director
calls cut or is it when he calls action
or she calls action because when it's
when um he or she calls it action action
yeah okay it's like um because they're
shooting it
um
I mean
for hopefully they don't rewrite your
your movie in post
[Laughter]
sometimes they do